it's friday so that means it's time to
make some plans with the weekender
this is our handpicked guide for your
weekend and we're kicking it off with
the must
do's meditation even the u.s army
recommends it
the week magazine one of my favorites
reports that it's the military's latest
holistic
health and fitness training manual it
suggests that
soldiers take naps fill half their plate
with veggies and yet
meditate when possible yes sir commander
sir i will nap when circumstances allow
sir
and that is a direct quote from the
manual
i know okay and what to watch in honor
of pet adoption week we're going back to
the vault with
best in show the dog show mockumentary
just turned
20 and it's like a fine wheel of cheddar
or a spreadable brie it only gets better
with age
i guess that doesn't really work bree
age now but it's
listen it's just it's candy you got
catherine o'hara and eugene levy
and this is christopher guest at his
very best jane lynch is in it
jennifer coolidge you got your parker
posey
so go watch it for the first or 100th
time
and you better find that busy bee fans
get it
okay for those looking to exercise check
out obeyfitness.com it's a subscription
service
that brings fitness classes right into
your home at the level that's most
comfortable for you
yoga bar weight training
dance prenatal postnatal
classes for seniors and yes you can
access it 24
7 so if you like to pump your pecs at
1am
pump away listen it's also a really
beautiful sight
gorgeously curated and a wonderful
destination to find yourselves in
oh and guess what it's time for the
little yellow book
my personal favorites that come to you
fresh every single week
on our site and it's about all the
things i love and i'm absolutely dying
to share with all of you
okay in it is the amped fleece
throw blanket from urban outfitters so
comfy
so plush and soft enough for a soldier
to nap on
vff's you don't even understand i got
one
and my girls and i literally fight over
it
okay so guess what you're all getting
one too
courtesy of urban outfitters
and i hope that you love it as much as
we do maybe you and your family can
fight over it too
and finally since all roads lead back
to condo you must try one of marie
condo's canvas wall
organizers it's great marie's great in
fact i have a hashtag
called closer to condo
and guess what my dreams are about to
come true
i just got word before the show that
it's confirmed
she's coming on the show on monday
sorry i'm just so excited oh my god
[Music]